How can a man who fathered a child also not
be that child’s father?
Nope, there’s no secret funny business with
the neighbour involved.
Just Chimerism.
Hey guys!
Amy with you on DNews today digging into the
totally fascinating world of chimerism!
In Greek mythology, Chimera is a fire-breathing
monster with the head of a lion, the body
of a goat, and the tail of a snake.
It is, in short, something that blends multiple
species and thus can’t possibly exist in
reality.
Except that chimeras do exist.
Scientifically speaking, a chimera is someone
with have multiple sets of DNA.
But if each individual has their unique DNA
signature, then a chimera is… two people…
rolled into one?
Actually, that’s kind of what’s happening.
It happens when an embryo takes in its twin’s
cells -- and therefore genetic material — in
utero.
Twins happen when a zygote splits.
But the moment of twinning — when the zygote
splits — is actually really important because
the later zygote separation occurs, the more
the two fetuses CAN share.
Two fetuses that don't entirely split can
become conjoined twins, but ones dies, it’s
the same thing as losing a pregnancy early
on but the remaining baby can be healthy.
It’s twin death in the first trimester that
we’re interested in looking at.
When one twin dies, its material is sometimes
absorbed into the surviving embryo causing
tetragametic chimerism.
This is more commonly known as Vanishing Twin
Syndrome.
The surviving embryo will develop with both
its and its twin’s DNA, meaning the child
will effectively be born its own twin.
This sounds nuts, but Vanishing Twin syndrome
is way more common that you might think!
In 1945, Dr. Stoeckel was the first to suggest
that the rate of multiple conceptions was
greater than multiple birth rates, that more
zygotes divide than grow into fully formed
twins and the dead twin material is reabsorbed
by the living twin without a trace — except
for the DNA trace.
Modern technology backs this with a rise in
two placentas detected early on with ultrasound
and only one heartbeat heard later on with
a sonogram.
It’s estimated that about one in every eight
single childbirths start as multiple pregnancies
with cells from the miscarried sibling occasionally
absorbed by the survivor.
Because our DNA is so fundamental to who we
are, there are some really interesting implications
with chimerism.
Like proof of parentage.
Two women — Lydia Fairchild and Karen Keegan
— didn't pass a maternity test.
They're not genetically the mothers of their
own children even though they physically gave
birth to them!
The same thing can happen with fathers.
In 2015, a US man failed a paternity test,
though he did seem to be his son’s uncle.
Doctor’s found that the DNA in his sperm
was different than the DNA in his saliva.
His vanished twin had fathered his child.
Like maternity and paternity testing, the
legal system relies heavily on DNA evidence.
In 2005, American cyclist Tyler Hamilton used
tetragametic chimerism as a defense against
positive blood doping results, claiming the
positive doping test was false because it
was actually his vanished twin’s blood.
And imagine if a chimera murdered someone.
DNA evidence on the scene could exonerate
the perpetrator even if circumstantial evidence
offers definitive proof of their guilt!
Our DNA is pretty fascinating, and if you
want to learn more about what makes us all
who we are, check out this video right here.
We’ll put a link in the description if you’re
on mobile.
What you didn’t know about your dna
So this is all a little creepy, but really
fascinating stuff!
What do you guys think about the possibility
of being your own twin?
Let us know in the comments below and don’t
forget to subscribe for more DNews every day
of the week.
So this is all a little creepy, but really
fascinating stuff!
What do you guys think about the possibility
of being your own twin?
Let us know in the comments below and keep
coming back to Test Tube for more DNews every
single day of the week.
So this is all a little creepy, but really
fascinating stuff!
What do you guys think about the possibility
of being your own twin?
Let us know on the Discovery News Facebook
page or on Twitter @DNews.
And you can find me; I’m @astvintagespace.
Thanks for watching!